let's go next to uh let's go to dave
from brooklyn
dave you were on the air hey david how
are you doing today
i'm doing well uh first thing i just
want to thank you because every day on
my drive home from work
i listen to you on youtube and um gets
me through the traffic
thank you i appreciate that um because i
have a new york city commute
i'm a high school teacher in the bronx
and i was
wanting to get your opinion about
something because i have been
frustrated for a few years now about the
lack of progress
that comes from the democratic party as
far as you know i'm a liberal minded
person but i don't identify as democrat
anymore because we keep
i don't want to say losing it's the
wrong word but we keep
failing to pass meaningful progressive
legislation and i think a lot of it is
due to
complacency which i think comes back to
something you talk about a lot which is
lack of epistemological skills
and i wanted your opinion on i see that
as a teacher on both sides
and i just feel that because on the left
we get fed more accurate information
and our media sources are generally more
honest
therefore it doesn't get shown as much
as it does on the right
but i feel and this is what i want your
opinion on that because of our
failing education system in a lot of
ways we don't have
on the left we also lack a lot of those
epistemological skills and i'm afraid
that in the future
that may come to uh come to the
forefront in a way that's more
meaningful than it does right now
because on the left
on the right on the right obviously it
has come to the forefront
so i think that you're not wrong
that the left sucker soft suckers the
left
suffers from a lack of epistemological
skills
too to some degree i don't think that's
actually the source of the left being
ineffective in the united states i think
it's actually a lack of rhetorical skill
i think it's
it's uh and george lakoff has written
about this a lot thomas frank has talked
about this a lot
um we on the left when you actually sit
down
and explain to people not with a
one-line
slogan like if you think about the
one-line slogans
on abortion right hey the right is
pro-life
anything other than that is anti-life
that's really effective if you just go
with a one-liner
when you really sit down with people and
you explain stuff to them
whether it's about you know 10 years ago
when you really talked in detail about
gay marriage or you talk about health
care now or whatever the case may be
the country is much more on the left
than
the representatives that we elect so
what's the problem i don't think it's
lack of epistemological skill i think
it's lack of rhetorical
skill by the left combined with and this
is the other part that's important
lack of a willingness to sort of just
like
power through the way that the right
does it i mean what mitch mitch
mcconnell i find to be a vile
and and a moral person but he's
essentially a republican hero not only
for what he's been able to get done for
republicans over the last decade but
what he's been able to stop democrats
from doing like if you're a republican
you've got to love mitch mcconnell for
what he's been able to do so i think
that the deficits for the democrats are
twofold
one lack of rhetorical skill in
uh uh talking about these issues in ways
that connect with voters
more and number two sort of a lack of
willingness to i'm not saying go
low in like commit crimes and do immoral
things
but like get down and really use
whatever legal
legal methods we can use to actually get
things done i think those are the issues
may i ask a very short follow-up
question yeah of course
so if i'm understanding correctly so i
heard you talk about a couple days ago
on your show when you were talking about
you're showing clips of some trump
spores at cpac yeah and they were
talking about getting out and doing
local
local activism right i was wondering you
know
it was what you're talking about related
in any way to like the effect
long-term effects of gerrymandering and
the drug war and local local voter
populations and all that kind of stuff
because that seems to be a place where
maybe in the long run democrats can
improve
absolutely and i guess that would be the
third piece which is the right
is just better at local politics than
the left it sucks that that's the case
but they're just
and by better i don't mean they're like
inherently better i don't mean they're
smarter
they're just doing it they're they're
carrying it out in a more effective way
and that includes school boards pta
city councillors etc uh yeah the
democrat i'm not a democrat either i
don't really care about the democratic
party as a party to the extent that we
can get some progressive things done
through the democratic party
great but i don't find it to be a
remotely competent political party
thank you so much david my pleasure all
right wow excellent
the these callers are basically as good
as the guests we were going to have so
i really can't complain